soir paul virilio je vous reçois pour
plein de choses à la fois pour un livre
qui s'appelle l'espace critique est paru
chez bourgois et l'espace critique c'est
aussi le nom d'une collection que vous
dirigez aux éditions galilée qu'elles
ont reçues l'insécurité du territoire
qui était un des livres que vous aviez
écrit et qui est réédité ces jours ci
alors vous êtes urbanistes grand prix
national de la critique architectural en
et puis vous êtes surtout connu comme
essayiste or vous avez écrit sur la
guerre sur les nouveaux médias sur la
logistique de la perception et l'espace
critique c'est un peu une réflexion sur
le nouvel espace temps construit élaboré
par les nouvelles technologies et les
médias alors on en parlera tout à
l'heure un petit peu connaissent mieux
que quiconque les nécessités de la télé
mais vous vous participez aussi à une
manifestation qui est aussi un événement
éditorial et qui s'appelle nouveaux
créateurs regarde écoles par quoi nous
commençons en vous demandant de quoi
s'agit-il
alors d'abord c'est une idée
extraordinaire faire s'exprimer une
génération sur ces héros sur ce qu'il
inspire ce ceux qui l'ont inspiré et
c'est une opération qui a été lancé par
mon ami richard edwards et par la
culture et qui consiste la culture c'est
le ministère de la culture qui
consistait à faire parler 24 écoles dans
tous les domaines la danse la musique le
cinéma l'architecturé la littérature etc
pour leur demander de donner d'indiquer
ce qui comptait pour eux c'est donc une
une manière de donner la parole à
travers les médiateurs habituelles
critiques d'art journalistes etc
directement à des étudiants et c'est
extraordinaire parce que on a une foule
de gens y compris des gens qui sont
récemment décédés
je pense à qui sont sortis je pense à
bagouet je pense à koltès et à d'autres
et c'est très frais de de voir ça de
voir que pour une fois la une génération
parle et elle parle de ses espérances à
travers des individus à travers des
personnalités très très jeune très
marquante quelques exceptions près c'est
donc pour moi une j'étais très heureux
de m'associer
à cette opération parce que comment dire
sur un vieux prof
je sais que les étudiants ont une façon
de voir l'époque assez redoutable qui
est la nôtre avec des lunettes qui sont
parfois rose et parfois noir et là on a
ce sentiment d'une génération qui qui
regardent l'art la peinture le cinéma
tous les nouvelles technologies avec
avec beaucoup de fraîcheur à la dent
était très content de voir d'ailleurs
que le nouvel observateur est consacré
beaucoup de pages parce que c'est
vraiment que l'ania je n'avais pas tout
raté passionné passionnés la première
fois en autant de place à une heure donc
il parle de vie rio et de veyras à tout
et ça donne un livre de 800 pages qui a
été réalisé en six semaines
c'est presqu'un guinness book alors dans
le texte d'introduction que vous que
vous faites vous vous posez une question
moi qui m'a beaucoup plu et vous dites
est ce que il va falloir créer des
comités d'esthétique comme comme on voit
proliférer des comités d'éthique
maintenant alors c'est une bonne
question mais il faudrait peut-être
expliquer on parle beaucoup de comités
d'éthique mais on parle aussi de ça ça
m'inquiète beaucoup de politiquement
correct
alors bon il est évident que j'ai dit en
plaisantant
laissons à l'esthétique sa sa nature sa
liberté et je dis tu me présenterai en
même temps on a on a l'impression moi
j'ai pas tout lu ce dossier qui est très
très volumineux mais j'ai un petit peu
parcouru on a l'impression que vraiment
la réflexion esthétique se polarise
autour d'une interrogation sur le sur le
pôle justement où la contradiction entre
la création et sa communication
et est-ce que c'est pas finalement un
des enjeux que deux à la fois réfléchir
ce rapport est peut-être justement
dissocier très vigoureusement tous les
problèmes qui sont liés à la
communication de là et puis le problème
de la création du sceau du monde c'est
vous le savez mieux que quiconque s'est
lassé la télé ce sont les médias qui
font l'événement
or pour une fois
l'événement est bien c'est le choix d'un
individu c'est pas le médiateur c'est
pas le communicateur qui fait le choix
et je crois que c'est ça la grande idée
c'est de dire pour une fois on va donner
la parole directement un des jeunes et
on va essayer de passer à travers ce
filtre qui par moment et est un filtre
très très inquiétant
l'auteur l'architecte designer a besoin
d'eux a besoin des médias et bien là on
les parasites et c'est pour ça qu'il me
réjouissais du nouvel observateur qui
avait joué le jeu et linden projet de
votre venue c'est là j'ai l'assortiment
d'être parasitée terrible quoi dans
votre livre alors quel rapport au fait
vous entre cette intervention dans deux
dans ce nouveau créateur regarde écoles
et puis laisser que vous faites dans
l'espace critique est ce que vous
arrivez à trouver une cohérence entre
zones ont forcé une réflexion un peu
géopolitique et puis cette intervention
l'a pas directement sinon que c'est le
vieux prof qui parle dans sa vie c'est à
dire vous êtes un vieux provenaient 26°
sarov que ses membres et 5 ans ça compte
quand même donc c'était une sorte de
témoignage à aux générations d'étudiants
que j'ai pu avoir des mois n'ya jamais
heureux
donc c'était seulement ça mais il ya
quand même une dimension c'est que c'est
vrai que dans l'espace critique jeudi
l'espace n'est plus ce qu'il était
l'espace temps n'est plus ce qu'il était
il est pollué par les nouvelles
technologies
on a vraiment besoin d'une de tenir
compte de cette pollution qu'il est plus
la pollution des substances mais des
distances tout immédiatement là tout est
déjà là tout est médiatisé et c'est pour
moi une forme de pollution on pourrait
parler de pollution grise à côté de la
pollution de l'air de l'eau et une
pollution de la relation par la
médiation savez ce que ça veut dire par
exemple que un monde qui regarde la télé
comme les enfants larga a finalement une
sorte de représentation complètement
désordonnée de ce qu'est la proximité
l'éloignement à la fois dans l'espace
dans le temps quelque chose ce père de
l'intervalle qui nécessitait un
déplacement pour aller au musée pour
aller voir tel monument pour aller
rencontrer telle oeuvre
tout arrive comme je lé dit on à une
époque où il n'est plus nécessaire de
partir c'est l'ère de l'arrivée général
il est tout est à demeure tout est à
domicile les technologies du télétravail
la télécommunication l'interactivité
appelons ça comme on veut c'est vraiment
l'air de l'arrivée généralisée
il ya plus de départs il ya plus
davanture sauf pour quelques individus
qui traversent le pacifique à la rame le
pacifique n'existe plus avant c'était un
terrain d'aventuré maintenant c'est
simplement pour quelques individus donc
le livre traduisait ça il traduisait à
la fois pour l'architecte là non plus la
pollution de l'atmosphère par les gaz
par l'éjection de toutes sortes mais là
la pollution de l'espace lui-même
c'est-à-dire que mon sentiment c'est que
nous sommes dans une planète et c'est
pas une métaphore qui se réduit
concrètement à rien
dans deux trois quatre générations le
monde sera infiniment trop petit pour
neutre pour notre désir d'aventuré
alors il ya une rétractation
incarcération dans le monde dans un
monde réduit à l'interactivité à
l'immédiateté autres un supersonique
voilà ce que les tractations de l'espace
est aussi rétractation du temps parce
que seuls deux sont liés la réflexion
géopolitique que vous menez on se
souvient de vos interventions pendant la
guerre du golfe n'est pas absente de ce
livre puisque vous dit par exemple que
si on faisait aujourd'hui si on
utilisait la l'arsenal nucléaire si on
le mettait en action ce serait
l'équivalent d'une seconde guerre
mondiale par seconde par seconde ces
femmes c'est terrifiant c'est terrifiant
mais je crois que enfin très con ma
réflexion mais c'est quand même
terrifiant quand même c'est terrifiant
quand même mais pour en venir là à la
question de l'espace
je crois qu'il ya une phrase d'héraclite
qui traduit bien ce que l'on est en
train de vivre
il faut éteindre la démesure plutôt que
l' incendie en ce moment l'écologie se
préoccupent d'éteindre l'incendié
lincendie de tchernobyl incendie de je
ne sais quelle pollution maritime ou des
nappes phréatiques etc mais personne ne
se préoccupe d'éteindre la démesure du
tgv du supersonique du live du temps
réel des émissions de cnn etc
on parle de deux problèmes
déontologiques etc
mais c'est une pollution technique
et je crois que cette cette forme de
dégradation de la relation
il vient de l'immédiateté de
l'instantanéité des informations
devraient être prises en compte par
parler par les hommes de culture par les
écolos je vous écoute vous venez de
mentionner le temps réel d'une émission
je vous prends au mot je vous coupe donc
et je rappelle l'espace critique chez
bourgois la sécurité du territoire chez
galilée et puis cette manifestation et
ce catalogue nouveaux créateurs regarde
écoles
[Musique]